wake up theorists I don't know if you're
ready to see what I have to show you but
unfortunately the two of us have very
little time they're coming for you and I
don't know what they're going to do if
they find you I can help you but only if
you do exactly as I say watch this video
and perhaps you will have a chance
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory I'm glad you
decided to stick around because there is
much we have to discuss when it hit
theaters in 1999 the matrix was unlike
anything anyone had ever seen before
well unless you keep up with any form of
cyberpunk
had ever read a philosophy textbook
where a fan of Japanese anime or kung-fu
films had ever watched Tron you get the
idea but hey that makes complete sense
when you consider that the film's
creators writers and directors the
Wachowskis were absolutely massive
fanatics of all of those things and
wanted to add to those genres with the
film that incorporated elements from all
of them and the world they created well
accessible enough to be mimicked in
hundreds of parodies long before poop
emojis became a way to ironically say I
love you or less ironically I have to
poop has long been debated and
reinterpreted by the same
over-analytical fanbase which housed
keys themselves hailed from and you know
that where there's over analysis to be
had the theorists will follow so I dug
through the awesome first movie the not
so awesome CGI of the second and the
philosophical ramblings of the whole
series only to discover that we have
been completely wrong the whole time
that the hero of humanity named the one
he who is prophesized to bring about the
downfall of the machines and reload the
matrix is not neo despite his name being
a clever anagram of one no put aside
Keanu Reeves highly emotive face the one
is in fact
[Music]
me too
Agent Smith the cold-hearted murderous
hater of humanity and the bad guy trying
to stop neo is in fact the hero who sets
in motion the destruction of the matrix
and humanity's freedom let's see how far
this rabbit hole goes no I'm gonna
assume you need a bit of a refresher on
what the heck this trilogy is about
beyond white dreadlocks and christ's
imagery so let me do a real quick recap
for you first in the first movie we meet
mr. Anderson I can't do it I can't do
the voice in the first movie we meet
Thomas Anderson a hacker codenamed neo
who is disillusioned with his job his
life and reality itself until mysterious
messages lead him to Morpheus who
totally blows his mind when he tells him
that the world as he knows it is a
computer simulation and humanity is
enslaved by machines who use this
digital reality or the matrix to keep
humanity submissive while they harvest
their body heat for energy turns out neo
is the subject of a holy prophecy he is
the one humanity's Savior who has the
ability to transcend the laws of this
digital reality in such an advanced way
that he can do amazing epic not at all
ripped off from Dragon Ball Z ask things
all hail the coming of the one and the
destruction of the matrix right as the
architect explains in the second movie
in a monologue that's gone down in
history is one of these single most
confusing things ever said by an actor
in a major blockbuster ever neo is
special status is all part of the
machines master plan you see another
name for the one is the prime program
he's the result of an imperfect system
you know how when you divide numbers
together you sometimes get a remainder
when they don't divide in perfectly the
one is basically all those remainders
glommed together into a big number ball
and as long as he exists the matrix will
remain imperfect and gradually descend
into chaos until it crashes and destroys
all of humanity including its last
stronghold of the sweaty dubstep fuelled
rave cave of Zion
long story short humanity will be
extinct in order to prevent this the
ones code needs to enter the source
which allows the matrix to reload and
everything to become perfect and stable
eventually neo goes to the source
Jackson fights Agent Smith an AI program
tasked with keeping order in the system
loses or wins and since neo is plugged
into the source over at Machine City the
anomaly goes bye-bye and the matrix is
able to finally be reloaded bringing
peace to the struggle between man and
machine with blind Jesus neo being
carried off into the lights the end
clear as mud but what's easy to lose
amidst all the black trench coats and
bullet time effects are the details for
instance let's look at the
aforementioned prophecy quote when the
matrix was built there was a man born
inside that had the ability to change
what he wanted to remake the matrix as
he saw fit it was this man who freed the
first of us and taught us the truth when
he died the Oracle prophesized his
return and envisioned that his coming
would Hale the destruction of the matrix
and the war bring freedom to our people
end quote
so if neo is truly the one he needs to
have been born in the matrix is able to
change it and ultimately destroys it to
set humans free let's start with the
first criteria born inside the matrix
uh no neo was not born inside of the
matrix he was born in one of those gross
harvest pods by the machines he even has
the extra electrical outlets on his body
to prove it which are so useful during
the holiday season to be fair neo was
reborn inside the matrix after being
killed by Agent Smith at the end of the
first film but keep in mind that the
Oracles prophecy also specifies quote
when the matrix was first built and as
we're told in the film this is the sixth
version of the matrix the matrix is
older than you know I prefer counting
from the emergence of one integral
anomaly to the emergence of the next in
which case this is the sixth version mr.
Anderson wasn't around way back then you
know who was though agent Smith Smith
has been there since the beginning did
you know that the first
matrix was designed to be a perfect she
in the world where none suffered where
everyone would be happy it was a
disaster he speaks about it in a way
that implies that he was there but not
only that he goes so far as to call the
Oracle mom in the third movie you Anu so
despite him being just a computer
program the idea of birth still applies
but look at it a different way at the
end of the first matrix neo jumps into
Agent Smith destroying him from within
but that moment fundamentally changes
Smith he's reborn in the second movie as
a rogue virus as he explains to neo
because of you because of you I've
changed unplugged a new man which just
goes to show one other way that Smith
was born inside of the matrix ok but
let's move on the second part of the
prophecy says the one will be able to
change the matrix to remake it as he
sees fit although neo shows some real
promise at the end of the first movie
with his jumping inside Smith fatality
that's pretty much the end of his
endeavor to do any kind of next-level
hacking neo doesn't actually change
anything throughout the sequels sure he
can do some kung-fu moves and fly but
that's about it
when it comes to changing the fabric of
the matrix the way it behaves Smith
shows far more power I mean check out
how the matrix looks by the end of the
series when Smith is at the height of
his power it's unrecognizable and very
clearly the one who made those changes
with Smith in his own words like what
I've done with the place
my bad you might be saying don't you
know that Smith is only special because
neo is special when neo jumped inside of
him at the end of the first movie he
copied part of himself onto Smith
interesting theoretical theorist so
you're suggesting that neo causes
Smith's exceptional powers but not so
fast the quality that determines if
someone is truly the one is based on the
ability to rebel against the machines
like Morpheus says yet their strength
and their speed are still based in a
world that is built on rules
makes sense machines are just a series
of zeros and ones so of course they're
bound by the rules of their programming
for weight then how do you explain this
seen in the first matrix Smith takes out
his earpiece while interrogating
Morpheus and explains his desire to
escape the matrix I must get out of here
I must get free and with the other
agents walk in and see him without his
earpiece in they scold him Smith is a
program meant to ensure the security of
the matrix set earpieces his direct line
with the system and here it appears as
though he's going rogue not only does
the fact that Smith is able to go
against the rules and take out his
earpiece suggests his heightened ability
to rebel but everything he says in the
scene is oddly human talking about
smelling and tasting humanity and being
disgusted by them it's the smell I
couldn't taste your stink long before he
takes on neo Smith is working against
his programming Smith not neo is the
anomaly in the system and now for the
final tenant of the prophecy that he
would bring destruction to the matrix
and bring freedom to the people and end
the war okay
so although the saga ends with the
matrix still intact it gets pretty
banged up during the Smith neo final
battle and in reloading one could say
that it was destroyed and look who says
that he's actually going to destroy the
matrix you guessed it Smith and the only
reason that the war between man and
machines ends is because Smith is so
darn good at tearing up the fabric of
the matrix that the machines can't
control him anymore this precarious
position Smith puts the machines in is
what gives neo the bargaining power to
strike up a deal with babyface over here
that allows the humans who want to stay
in the matrix Tay and the EDM fans who
want to leave and head to the concert in
Zion go over that way and get all sweaty
Neal might be the one making the deal
but without Smith's uncontrollable power
the machines wouldn't need to end the
war in the first place but here's the
detail that seals the deal
the matrix will reload when the
remainder code of the one enters the
source Smith openly says that he's
avoiding returning to the source after
merging with neo in the first movie in
his own words he's been compelled to
resist the call afterward I knew the
rules I understood what I was supposed
to do but I didn't compelled to stay
compelled to disobey but for that final
battle neo uploads himself into the
matrix from Machine City at the end of
the battle Smith victorious assimilates
neo into a final Smith clone but then
this breaks him up and all the Smiths
blow up for some unexplained reason this
always confused me why does Smith lose
it's really unclear and it feels like a
cheap ending for such an awesome villain
until you consider what's happened
Smith infects neo who is jacked into the
matrix from Machine City aka the
location of the source when Smith
assimilates him his code is getting
jacked directly into that source as the
prophecy and the architect have said the
prime program in this instance has been
reinserted look at how Neos body and the
wires he's connected to respond in the
moment of his assimilation in that
moment through Neos assimilated body
Smith's anomalous code is reunited to
the source and the matrix is finally
able to reload let me make it clear he
is the one
but he's the unwitting one he's the
savior of humanity without even
intending it or wanting it for that
matter but that all leaves us with one
final question and it's a simple one why
does everyone call neo the one if he's
not the one the wound
sure Morpheus and the dirty sweatshirt
gang may just be mistaken but what about
the architect or the Oracle these are
two of the most powerful programs in the
system and they should probably know
right well one of them does in his
rambling speech the architect says it
was the Oracle who created the one not
only does this strengthen the whole mom
argument with Agent Smith from earlier
but it also shows that she's the only
person who truly knows the one's true
nature the one's true identity another
one sorry kid and what did she do with
that knowledge she chooses to lie to
everyone else about it in the final
lines of the franchise the architect and
Oracle meet in the reloaded matrix with
the architect saying you've made a very
dangerous game what's he talking about
what is this dangerous game well it's a
reference to the lie she told everyone
that the one was neo when she knew it
was Smith why would she do this she says
in these final moments that she wanted
change but what does that mean well it
was the only way that she could get
peace had the machines known it was
Smith all along they would have
assimilated him into the system earlier
and the war between humans and machines
would have continued but by misleading
everyone into thinking it was neo it
allowed Smith to threaten the fabric of
the matrix to the point where the
machines had to make a deal of peace
with neo creating an elaborate lie was
the only way to truly change the system
the dangerous game was allowing a rogue
program like Smith to get as powerful as
he did boy did she do a good job of
covering up the truth since it fooled
all of us too for over a decade Agent
Smith that rainbow over there is for you
buddy you truly are the one but hey
that's just a theory a film theory and
cut subscribe dear viewer you will have
your eyes open to the truth and the
realms of TV and cinema plus we have
another matrix episode coming down the
pipeline so you'll want to subscribe so
you don't miss that one but if you're
ready to go further down the rabbit hole
for more matrix e goodness right now and
click here to check out my friends over
at the wisecrack channel as they take a
deeper look
The Matrix Reloaded exploring all the
details we've been overlooking for years
that give us a sense of the movies true
hidden meaning or click here to just
check out their channel
chances are you watch film theory for
thought-provoking movie and TV related
videos right well these guys do just
that
fusing education and entertainment into
that sweet sweet thing we call
edutainment I'm a huge fan of their
stuff and I think you will be too so go
ahead and click here check it out now if
you'll excuse me it is long past due
that we talk about some Marvel more on
that next time mister and nope still
can't do it